>> Tucker: THE NUMBER OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS STREAMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER HAS JUST HIT A NEW
ALL TIME RECORD.
NEVER BEFORE HAVE WOE SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
MORE THAN A QUARTER OF A MILLION
FOREIGN NATIONALS WERE STOPPED
LAST MONTH ALONE.
THAT'S AN INVASION IF THAT'S THE
WORD FOR IT.
IT'S AFFECTING EVERY PART OF
AMERICAN LIFE AND HAVING AN
AFFECT ON FARMERS AND ALEX MUIR
IS A FARMER IN YUMA, ARIZONA AND
JOINED US TO TELL US WHAT HE'S
BEEN EXPERIENCING AND ALEX,
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
SO WE DON'T HEAR OFTEN ENOUGH
FROM PEOPLE IN BORDER STATES
ABOUT WHAT IT LOOKS TO THEM.
WHAT'S YOUR EXPERIENCE BEEN?
>> WELL, HELLO, TUCKER.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
IT'S OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS,
IT'S JUST BEEN DEATH BY 1,000
CUTS AND BEEN A SLOW TRICKLE.
AND WE'RE SEEING IT EVERY DAY
AND WE'RE RIGHT.
THIS IS THE END OF THE BORDER
HERE.
AND WE HAVE A FIELD OF LETTUCE
HERE AND THE COMMUNITY HERE HAS
SEEN AN UP TICK IN CROSSERS AND
IT'S JUST BEEN CONTINUOUS AND
CONTINUOUS AND IT'S TAXING AND
IT'S HARD FOR US TO DO OUR JOBS
WHEN WE HAVE THE UTMOST WORK AND
WE HAVE TO CART IT OFF AND FLAG
IT AND WE DON'T HARVEST THAT
AREA AND WE CAN'T HARVEST THAT
AREA AND 20 OR 30 PEOPLE SAY
THERE'S 100 OUT THERE ABOUT A
QUARTER OF A MILE DOWN AND
MOSTLY THEY CROSS AND THERE'S
GAPS ALONG THE WALL THAT THEY'RE
CROSSING OVER AND IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL ASPECT OF THE JOB OUT
OF THE WHEELHOUSE.
>> Tucker: YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO CONTEND WITH BORDER SECURITY,
YOU'RE A LETTUCE FARMER AND THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE DOING THAT FOR YOU.
THAT'S THEIR MAIN JOB.
THAT'S WHY THEY EXIST AND HOW
ARE THEY AND WHY AREN'T THEY?
APPARENTLY THEY'RE NOT.
WE LIVE IN BORDER PATROL AREAS
AND THE BORDER PATROL ARE
GLORIFIED TRAVEL AREAS AND
PEOPLE CROSS THE -- DOWN HERE A
QUARTER MILE AND THEY PUT PEOPLE
ON BUSS AND TAKE THEM TO A TENT
CITY AND WHERE THE STATION IS
AND PROBABLY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE THERE AT ANY GIVEN TIME
AND GIVING THEM BUS PASSES OR
AIRPLANE TICKETS AND IT'S BEEN
INSANE TO WATCH FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED HELP DOWN HERE AND WE WANT
TO BRING LIGHT TO THE SITUATION.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
YOU'RE SO METICULOUS IN YOUR JOB
THAT IF A COYOTE CROSSES INTO
YOUR FIELD, YOU'LL NOT SELL THE
PRODUCE THE COYOTE TOUCHED.
HERE'S THE GOVERNMENT ABETTING
CRIME AND PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO BE
STOPPING THE CRIME IS MAKING IT
POSSIBLE AND REWARDING THEM WITH
FREE AIRLINE TICKETS AND HOW
DOES IT FEEL?
>> WE'RE COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND AT A TIME WHERE
COSTS ACROSS THE BORDER ARE UP,
FUEL COST UP 30% AND FUEL COSTS
UP 30% AND ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT
GETS SENT DOWN TO THE END USER
AND THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF WHAT WE DO.
MY WIFE'S FAMILY WAS FARMING FOR
75 YEARS AND WE'RE ONE OF THE
YOUNG GUYS ON THE BLOCK AND
WE'RE PROUD OF THIS AND WE'RE
PROUD OF WHAT WE PROVIDE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE'S A COUPLE STORIES AND
BORDER PATROL AGENT FRIEND OF
MINE SAW SOMEBODY CROSSING THAT
HAD TWO PEOPLE CROSSING WITH HIM
AND HE WAS PAYING TO CARRY HIS
LOUIE VITTON LUGGAGE AND SAW A
5-YEAR-OLD CROSSING ALONE WITH A
PHONE NUMBER PINNED TO HER
CHEST.
I SAW THAT WITH MY OWN EYES AND
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR TWO YEARS
AND WE NEED HELP DOWN HERE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT IN OUR
WHEELHOUSE, IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THE CITY OF YUMA NEEDS TO DEAL
WITH.
WE'D LIKE TO GET SOME HELP.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU GET IT.
THIS IS AN ATROCITY.
EXPRESSION OF DEEP DISRESPECT
FOR THE